today's topic for promoting body
positivity but former Biggest Loser
trainer Jillian Michaels wonders if she
should if she should be take a look
why are we celebrating her body why does
it matter that's what I'm saying like
why aren't we celebrating her music
because it isn't gonna be awesome if she
gets diabetes well I'm just being honest
like I love her music like my kid loves
her music but there's never a moment
where I'm like I'm so glad that she's
overweight like why do we why do I even
care why is it my job to care about her
weight cuz you're somebody who
apparently helps people lose weight or
put weight on it that's why people
assume that you would care wow that's a
bit of a misrepresentation what's he
saying she's like she doesn't want to
glorify I think anybody would agree that
if you love yourself at any point
everyone's gonna be positive nobody
wants you to be depressed in whatever
state or whatever place you are you know
but no one also wants to look at what
you're going through and the size that
you're at and be like that's a great
thing because let's be honest it's not
you know it kills me that people say
this when it comes to black people not
realize that black people deal with all
kinds of health issues in North America
you know we have plenty of people in the
black community who are very prominent
who are dying from high blood pressure
who are dying from diabetes a lot of
preventable stuff for example Patrice
O'Neal died from diabetes Patrice is a
good example for me because that's
someone who I feel like today would have
so much to contribute to society but
because of the way that we're all like
I'm not saying he felt victim to that
party positivity but because the fact
that unlike me we eat so unhealthy we're
losing people who are really valuable to
stuff that is preventable obesity is one
of the leading cause of deaths that is
preventable it's sad to me it's honestly
sad so I understand what she's saying
because at the end the day I wouldn't
want that for my child but if my child
was in that state where they were you
know obese and she said I still love
myself I'm happy about the fact that she
still loves herself and she's still
positive but I would not say that that's
a good place to be and all these stars
who say all this body positivity stuff
and they're like yeah yeah you find out
years later they lose all that weight
whether it's Adele whether it's Monique
I'm not saying people should go out
there infection I'm not saying
like you're fat you should insult people
like that but on the flip side we should
always be honest you can have real
conversations about how this stuff is
unhealthy how this stuff isn't good
first well you don't know someone's
health just by looking at them yes okay
there are some obese people who are
actually doing okay generally speaking
this is pretty accurate for the general
curb when you are obese you are raising
your likelihoods up early death I can't
stand when liberals are the ones that
are pushing this stuff and knowing damn
well that the communities most affected
by obesity or minority communities so we
liberal elites in Hollywood be like oh
yeah body positivity boo boo stop I see
what it's doing the people I see how
it's removing people from our community
serves people taking people out of jobs
because the fact that their feet don't
work because their diabetes you can say
that because you're rich and you're
insulated from that stuff so you could
push this message to everyone but for
the people who are most affected they
can't afford doctors meetings you know
how expensive it is for insulin
medication yeah in the states it's a
scary thing to deal with I would never
wish that on somebody else when wenzer
Vale said yo you don't live among this
life yeah sit down sit just take your
award thank you God and you know we're
not celebrating her body we're
celebrating the fact you are no
celebrate well I'm not I'm celebrating
the fact that she likes her body that
she's
[Applause]
I don't think there's a difference I
think celebrating her body I'm thrilled
that she's a big figured woman I'm
thrilled that she is and that she has no
compunction about where whatever she
wants to wear and she's comfortable you
know so high and I do celebrate Jillian
Michaels is entitled to her opinion but
not everybody can be a skinny okay
Midler first huh
I didn't know you could say the B word
on national attention yeah yeah it gives
me the hypocrisy of this show where it's
like yeah don't make fun of big people
but let's make fun of skinny people cuz
skinny people can be unhealthy to skinny
people are humans you know I mean you
cannot skinny shame them as well because
we do that you know how many times I've
seen people my friends are continued
like yo eat a sandwich yeah get that
person a sandwich
oh my god you don't crack oh there's the
wind outside with some rockets in your
pocket the number of time I heard that
and I got some fans that go clean
up because we had discussion are you
happy yes you are and that's how your
body should be perfect fine no problem
as long as you're not hurting yourself
but the minute some of my friends that
are bigger they're like yeah I start to
have sleep apnea I'm always tired
I'm always did and I'm like maybe is
because of something but it must be the
most North American thing to be lazy and
fat but it must be this is the only
place I've ever heard of where people
like you're exercising that's disgusting
probs do you know how important
exercising is to happiness to do like
the endorphin release how it is it
important for your health longevity your
mobility you want to be around for your
grandkids I hope you exercise do you
want to be part of your family's life
for a long time I hope you exercise in
communities like China right they have
literally 40 events that they do in the
park for all the old people yeah the
exercising should be part of your
day-to-day life you should want to be
moved and you want to be active it is so
sad to me how we acted into the North
America in regards to fitness
it is like either you're on the extreme
where you go to the gym all the time or
you're the other apathetic person who
makes fun of it I'm like you guys are
backwards
did you just hit yourself a man yeah
because this is so dumb I want to knock
it out I can't believe I'm hearing this
stuff bro I could help you sister Pro
long walks are healthy for you like it
makes me sad because I see old people
who are staying in and we refused to
exercise and you see their mobility and
I went here when he don't move it kills
them it literally kills your body and
this is woman's getting on national TV
and she's saying this stuff and I'm like
she can say this because she has access
to the best health best best doctors
best everything but a lot of those old
peoples who are stuck in those homes and
who don't want to do anything they're
stuck in this endless cycle of like
lethargy and they just don't move
because you're gonna be like oh dinner's
ready oh I gotta go eat cuz that's
your cook that's it then well you look
like you're on death's door like once
you remove that wig and on that makeup
you don't look like you got much time to
live I wouldn't be surprised if for the
next 10 year you hear the fact that Joy
Behar die listen some people are happy
doing crack some people are happy doing
all kinds of stuff some people are happy
running other people over some people
are happy burning themselves doesn't
mean that it's the right thing for
society this propensity towards
happiness in this North America sighting
is dumb can we just be happy what's
right and what makes you happy to be two
different things so years people were
they could fat shame and they could
exclude people and they could make
people feel less than in all forms of
media and we should always be inclusive
but you cannot glorify obesity it
it's dangerous it kills people it's the
number one cause of bankruptcy in our
country so there's a middle ground here
now it's like oh that woman is 250
pounds good for her and it's like it
shouldn't be one way or the other it's
really no one's business to comment it's
not something you should judge it's not
something you should celebrate that
woman's health is up to her
but I mean 250 pounds I would say 999
times out of a thousand is going to mean
heart disease cancer diabetes autoimmune
issues in early death like I also just
don't get why we're celebrating
mediocrity it's easy to be overweight it
is easy no you gotta buy all those real
you gotta walk over there bro you have
to eat all the time that's not easy then
you can we got a fresh salad there you
have to choose the Caesar salad because
it's mayonnaise in there and not the
green salad like it's choices that you
make easy what are you talking about
yeah I get you man so then when we
celebrate JLo is because even at her age
she's taking the time and putting in the
work in order to stay in shape now maybe
there's other extracurriculars that I
don't know you're just doing but all
this to say that's why we celebrate the
fitness size it because it's difficult
it's like an anything when I watch
sports
I don't celebrate the worst players I
celebrate the best players because
they're winning at the highest level
when you listen to music who do you
celebrate the best musicians so of
course I don't think it makes sense to
celebrate the worst of the worst because
they're not good at what they're doing
that's me though maybe you have a
different the way we use it's all about
obese people is that dehumanizing yeah
and that's what the problem is with fat
shaming you know dehumanizes people and
that's what people are going against now
I understand that there's a difference
between dehumanizing people and
celebrating what is killing a bunch of
people there's a difference and that's
what we have to be nuanced you know what
I mean I'm not for fetching me and I
understand how bad fat shaming is
actually for some people fat shaming can
get them to change their behavior and
some people fat shaming can actually
keep them in the same gave your because
they don't have the courage to do
something else you understand what I'm
saying so I understand how bad the fat
shaming is and how it's important not to
do it but there's a difference between
fat shaming and over gratification of
obesity something that is killing
someone is just like you should smoke
shame people that are smoking outside
because they have the right and it makes
them happy to smoke outside and just to
release endorphins and just to be
relaxed and computer they fine okay but
it is also killing a lot of people and
at the end of the data people that get
the bill is people that living
it changes like I've been overweight
I've been closer to 40 I have brought
your body feels different your feet
start to swell you don't move as well
getting up is different you feel a
thorak in the morning my snoring got
worse it was not a good place to be and
I didn't realize how much I preferred
the other side of it until I lost that
weight and then I was like oh because
here's the thing when you are somewhere
and you're used to being there you don't
know what it feels like to live in a
different place so you just get used to
that
but you don't realize even when you lose
that weight it's like what you notice is
the absence of a lot of negatives and
it's hard to notice the absence of
negatives it's not like being happy
where it's a high this is just a place
where you're like I'm not in a bad place
anymore you know I'm saying so it's it's
interesting to me that I noticed that
difference and I'm like all people don't
want that I'm like trust me if most
people had the choice to be able to move
better to feel better to physically be
able to do things better live a longer
life I think most people would opt for
that so that was my personal experience
but I just want to smell my friends that
were overweight Andy decided to change
is because they had a close call and
after that close call like it was a it
was a light that some people had strokes
yeah some of my people had they were
fainting a lot high blood pressure and
then they change are like wow I never
thought that I got never felt better
that way so it's really not so much
about being fat or whatever it's really
about being healthy with the age
eventually that catches up the
hundred that thing catches up I love me
some soul food so food is killing us
just refer yourself to the big Beulah's
episode oh listen yeah they call it soul
food or for a reason yeah because the
Dean has left the soul cause he died
[Music]
America North America is one of the very
few places where we talk about this
stuff this way the rest of the world has
clued in to this and they watch their
portions because we overeat here I feel
like it's the food industry who's really
pushed this whole or you body positivity
you're gonna maybe it's a conspiracy
I don't know but to me it's very suspect
than a place where we overeat this much
that body positivity is constantly
pushing I don't think it's them I don't
think it's a food place I think it's
more the the pharmaceuticals because
they're the one racking up on that sure
I mean a healed client is it's not a
client anymore
right so I mean maybe that's what it is
no no I'm not gonna go into conspiracies
and see lies like that I cannot go in to
think that I cannot prove like who's
pushing it and who's not pushing it I
don't know I can't prove it but I'm
gonna go with this it's just it's just
that it's just facts in your younger
years is gonna be fine later on you're
gonna have problems and that's pretty
much it yeah same thing if you're too
skinny later on you're gonna have you
you should have your weight you should
have the weight that you have and that's
all that's all good if you're healthy
you're LZ but if you start to have
problems and it starts to be a problem
you should do something about it